uh
when you think about a conference uh you
can draw some parallels to
what a conference is versus our sort of
daily work
that we do uh in some ways a conference
is kind of our olympics or it's kind of
our space launch or our
grand prix and i guess we all kind of
just win
by being here together i mean
it's not every day that you get to
launch rockets uh but i think that this
is
this is one of those such occasions and
i think we should enjoy being here
together especially at the first css
comp here in asia which i think is
incredible because singapore is
amazing
and uh i i'm really really happy to be
here as well
today my talk is not uh it's not about
code it's about being a coder i guess or
designer i'm asking the question
what are we doing anyway and i talked
about the space launch as if that was
something that
we aren't sort of really doing um
you know we're often like this is our
environment we sit
looking at a terminal with a blinking
cursor and we're typing in there all day
or maybe uh we're hitting reload all day
and swearing at a browser and looking at
the box model
and i think what's really kind of
interesting uh when you think about what
it is that we do
we you know i mean before the web was
this intangible thing you know when we
had big crt monitors that sat
on the back of our desks uh you know it
like we had no connection to uh to the
web but what's really interesting about
now
is that we're just surrounding ourselves
in those screens and they're just
smaller they're in our pockets and
they're in our bags
and they're on our tiny laptops and so
we don't have tangibility over our work
really but it's just closer so we tell
ourselves that it's okay and we're
actually building something physical
but we're not anyway
i'll introduce myself super quickly uh
i'm ben
i'm from melbourne australia um
i'd say that i was a designer but i
would be lying
i didn't go to design school i did art
in
high school and that was about my uh
sort of design background i studied
multimedia design
i'd say i was a developer but i didn't
study computer science
um so i guess i would say that i was
uh i just build things for the web um
i'm mostly self-taught uh like probably
a lot of you are
i certainly didn't start doing stuff for
the web because it was easy to describe
to my parents
uh i just did it because i was working
on a computer and i was really
interested in how i created something
and i think that's probably true for for
a lot of you here um how many people are
self-taught
like a fair few okay maybe i don't know
um i think i think you know maybe uh we
get into doing what we're doing because
we have this sort of dedication to a
creative endeavor or
we're just chasing a desire to learn how
to do something
also i forgot to mention it so i'm a
contractor i work for
sort of maybe four to six companies a
year
uh i'm one of the three founding members
of css conf australia
uh and uh i just try to build stuff
that i enjoy doing and that's that's
what my talk today about is about
um but the actual fact is that i have no
idea what i'm doing
today i'm going to talk about fun
and goofy or fun slash goofy
over profit so let's think about that
for
for a second what is fun and goofy fun's
pretty self-explanatory but what is
goofy
uh goofy means like foolish or just
harmlessly eccentric
and so i'm talking about the the idea of
building things just for the hell of it
just for like the sake of learning or
just for having fun
so i would say i'm doing this but i have
no idea why
i just am brad boss
at cascadia.js said creative code is an
experiment with a goal of surprising and
delighting
um i think it's much easier to say that
something's goofy but that's just me
he also goes on to say that
when you do something that is uh an
experiment uh
you do it because it might make you a
better engineer uh you don't necessarily
need to quit your job but
you know maybe you should just take a
day off and try to build something
so i'm going to tell you a story can i
bring water maybe
somebody's water i'm going to drink it
anyway
tastes good all right so i'm going to
tell you a couple of stories
um today uh and they're just sort of
points in
in my career over the last 13 years
they're not like the best things i've
ever worked on
uh they're not things that maybe made
more money than
other stuff that i've done but i think
they're interesting for the sake of
they were really fun but they were
seriously goofy
okay one afternoon
uh sometime in 2009 i was uh i was
actually putting together a series of
html5 workshops this is when
historified was a new thing we still
called it html5 for it for one thing
i was i went to a meetup and i said hey
i think i'm
going to maybe do some workshops who
would be interested in doing it it's
going to be a whole day
it'll be 300 bucks who wants to come
70 people in the room put their hands up
and i sort of looked at the ground
really nervously and i said i'll get
back to you
and two weeks later i put a side up and
i sold all of my tickets in like an
hour suddenly i had like fifteen
thousand dollars in my bank account and
i had no idea what i was doing
uh i had a date i had a venue but i
still had no idea what i was doing
and i guess what i wanted to do was i
just wanted to know
everything i didn't want somebody to be
able to say
well what happens when it doesn't work
in this browser or what happens in this
situation i didn't want to
be wrong so i started reading w3c specs
and i just wanted to know how does
everything work i'll just
i'll just read everything and
nobody would be able to prove me wrong
and i started and i quickly realized
that w3c specifications are not built
for
normal people they're built for people
who build browsers
and so i mean i was going to get to the
workshop eventually i was eventually
going to start preparing that
i mean it was only in a week and i had
only you know taken a lot of people's
money by that point
and so i was madly researching i took
like time off work and i was just
reading and researching and trying to
develop this content um
but i stopped and i just did something
as a little hack project one afternoon
uh i went into dev tools and i started
messing around with the the developer uh
in for like the spec information
i started uh changing margins and
tweaking the typography and changing the
line heights of everything
just trying to make everything more
readable because i didn't really want
what i was looking at and i thought hey
this is this is pretty cool
um maybe i'll maybe i'll show it to a
co-worker and you know
maybe i'll make a little bookmarklet out
of this thing and so i did and i tap you
know
quickly as fast as i could in under an
hour uh
made this little bookmarklet that
basically took the spec
added these weird styles that i decided
were better than the other ones for
whatever reason
uh and i i showed it to my friend
anthony uh pushed
it to github and a day or two later i
just tweeted like
oh hey here's some user styles um
good luck that was it i thought the
project was over
and for the next three hours i watched
my phone explode
in ways that i had never seen my phone
explode
i had been working on open source for a
long time and i was kind of building
things that i thought were
interesting i wasn't really getting that
much attention and this thing that i
just kind of threw together when i was
just messing about
you know procrastinating essentially
suddenly was making my phone melt on my
desk
on the fourth hour paul irish retweeted
it
my phone exploited for the rest of the
evening
and um the next day paul got in touch
and he actually sent me a pull request
and the pull request was like oh hey i
fixed your fonts in firefox because
cross-domain issues it wasn't working
whatever i said hey cool thanks paul
um merged it i was like oh my god this
guy actually knows who i am
this is super cool paul's one of my
heroes
and uh the next thing was i got an email
from him saying
hey what are you on chat suddenly paul
messaged me and he's like hey what up
that was seriously the conversation that
was i looked back through my message
history that was the message he sent me
friendliest guy ever and what was really
interesting was that like
like i said this was something that i
just threw out and i didn't think was
important or
interesting even i was just doing it for
the hell of it
but it wasn't just paul other people
kept coming out of the woodwork
other people from organizations like w3c
and people like steve sauders and people
who work for browser companies were
actually interested in the work that i
was doing
people that i respected you know it
wasn't just dorks on the internet these
were like
my heroes a little while later this is a
great shot of me
mid speech i look much younger and but
still good looking of course
uh so this is my talk from web
directions uh 2010
so this was a little bit longer and i
was on this whole tip about how evil the
w3c were
uh they are so yeah it's fine um
what was really fun that in in between
those few months of me throwing out this
little bookmarklet
and this point here was that mike
smith from w3c got in touch uh and i
actually
went to tokyo for a conference or
something else
and uh mike said you want to grab a beer
like of course i want to grab a beer
let's hang out let's let's
meet each other and
what followed was really interesting
mike had actually been working on a
specification
that he called html5 for authors
and the idea of html5 for authors was
that he took the w3c spec
removed all of the crazy browser
implementation crap
and uh just shipped a much smaller
version of the spec it looked the same
but it was the content was slightly
different smaller
and we kept talking and you know we're
uh you know chatting a little bit
from the same talk this is from you know
the same the same moment in time
uh during this talk uh mike and i had
been working together
and uh we actually took my my styles and
pulled them out of the bookmarklet and
fixed them and worked on it for a bit
and uh you'll see um this is mike here
and what we did during this talk was
i mean he worked for w3c and he had
access to deploy
stuff uh so we didn't ask anybody but we
just took the user styles and put them
on his spec on the w3c site and hit
deploy
from the front row of my talk which i
thought was the coolest thing in
the world
and then i realized holy my work is
running on their domain
i got pulled down you really want to
know but
it lasted a few weeks but some people
weren't so happy
it was it was pretty amazing
a little bit later on after a few months
of nagging paul
irish convinced me to start joining rc
he told me a few channels to join
and this conversation took place
i actually took this from the logs from
2010.
uh so ian hixson
oh my god where did we go
there it is um so hixi up here was like
oh hey
uh i thought this was really cool the
work that you did
what do you say we put it on wg
so we did we uh we shipped this
uh a month or so later he just gave me
access to deploy whatever i wanted and
here we are
it's been online for five years now uh
it was the first w3c
extended spec that you know obviously my
wg so i was
kind of forked at that point but that's
a whole other story
uh it was offline capable so you could
go onto your tablet and it would sync
down to your device and it was just
documentation looked a little bit better
whatever that was cool but i had no
freaking idea that when i sat there in
writing a goofy little bookmarklet that
i shared to one friend that this would
happen months later that i'd be working
with these people
so as an extension of my uh talk
i wanted to talk more about commercial
versus fun and dawn
it's entirely possible that you here uh
will
work you know a full busy busy lucrative
career
doing good work for good people uh and
your impact on the world will actually
be minor you're not gonna disrupt an
industry
you're not gonna you're not gonna fix
anything you're just going to build good
stuff
for good people and that's okay that's
totally fine
one of the frustrating things about our
industry is that projects die
and when a project dies underneath you
you lose a little bit of yourself too
how many show of hands how many times
have you lost something after three
months of work
not too many six months 12 months like
entire products disappearing there's a
couple of folks
even good projects die
i worked on a few projects that died
after uh investing
a lot of time and money into them and
they disappeared from underneath me and
i had no idea that
they even kind of came or left
and i now i guess you know i work for
myself and i
pay my own salary and i'm i'm the person
who maintains my own happiness and i'm
the person who has to pay my salary in
my super and worry about when my next
contract's coming in and
if the contract's good and if i need to
like yell at my client for some reason
it kind of sucks but
i think it's really important that we
focus for fun
this is where we're going to start
talking
so this is a project that
started in my office uh we were drinking
beer
it was uh 35 degrees so it was kind of
singaporish
um we were in a warehouse office that
had no air conditioning so it was
35 degrees inside we were you know
beating sweat down our heads
and we'd all been doing client work for
the day and we're all kind of
a little bit over it in the office we
had just bought a projector
and so basically we were projecting
anything we could onto the wall uh
funnily enough we started just
projecting gifts because gifts
here are the people who were there
there's me eating a doughnut probably
wasn't eating a donut right now
there's glenn madden there's tim lucas
and there's uh josh
so this order um
myself glenn and tim are css conf
australia by the way
and josh is just a rad friend that was
so visiting the office that day
and we sat down and we started working
on this thing called gift city
i'm going to show you give city um
hopefully
just remember this is the internet and i
don't moderate this content so
if anything comes up that shouldn't i'll
do my best
where's mine okay
okay
cool okay so this is gift city
uh gift city as you can tell is full
screen gifts
cool uh
it has basically no features
except for this guy up here where are we
okay
so what give city does is we take the
name of a tumbler
and we hit the tumbler api and we just
look for gifs
pretty great right um we have
only a couple of features we have the x
button which if a gif comes up that's a
little bit rude for the office it is
tumblr after all
you hit x and it will remove that gif
and never ever show it again
it's kind of great and the gifts are
random
this is one of my favorite tumblers
called classics but in the source
we actually
in the source we actually keep a list of
a couple of our favorite tumblers in
here
uh let's see let's find some good ones
we got some adventure time fans here
no want just right come on
you're lying to me adventure time is the
best
okay uh and so what's happening here is
it's hitting the tumbler api
uh for both the classics tumblr blog and
the adventure time gifts blog
uh it's found that many gifs and it just
keeps traversing through
the api and trying to download more and
more and more gears
uh as you'll notice uh the url bar
updates
uh and the query string shows the
tumblers that we we actually have in
there so
if you wanted to you could actually uh
edit the url
you actually go and edit the url
you just put anything in there and it
goes and downloads them
it's pretty great
anything else no okay
we set a couple of rules for the for a
gift city uh we weren't allowed to use
any javascript libraries
uh we weren't allowed to use any
javascript to do the like little
uh pop-down thing for that we're using
the css target selector because
why would you use javascript because
we're css badasses of course
uh and we didn't want to use libraries
we just wanted to find and dumb
javascript you know smash an api and put
your api key in the source code of
course that's gonna be amazing
um we focused on fun and so a couple of
things happened like we were doing this
in our office and drinking beer and
hanging out it was pretty great
and when somebody else would come in the
office we would just start like putting
gift city on and showing them gifts and
playing music and you know just inviting
people into our office to hang it
and we kept going
let's see okay cool
we kept going and we thought we were
really cool
we started going to hack events and camp
js's and stuff like that and there was
one point where we uh at a new year's
eve party we were projecting gifts
40 40 foot high onto a factory building
across from the rooftop that we were on
which we thought was pretty cool kind of
built i guess
we took a projector to a camp
and dragged out a cable that was 50
meters long a power cable
and started projecting onto trees
it didn't really end there for like tim
and josh and myself it ended there we
were done
but glenn wasn't quite done
glenn kept hacking we kept as i said
going to parties and playing stuff and
hanging out and glenn was like you know
what would it be really cool if the
gifts were synced to music
wouldn't that be great wouldn't it be
great if we could like hook it up to a
turntable and like have an analog
control for the gifts so we could
scratch it backwards and forwards
wouldn't that be great wouldn't it be
great if we could like
put the gifts in 3d and shoot pixels of
gifs at the camera
wouldn't it be great wouldn't it be
great if we could like
just have like gifs decoded in the
browser
wouldn't it be great like it just kept
going and
we humid him for a little while but to a
point we were like
glenn i we need to work just please
leave us alone
and glenn kept just writing code more
code and more code and more code
he was experimenting a lot doing weird
stuff and he was somebody who had never
written javascript before
not much anyway little bits
glenn went on and he wrote something
called xgif uh which is a
web component that actually uh
implements a tag in the browser called
x-give it has only a couple of options
you can set a gif to loop you can set
its playback speed
and you can do some other interesting
things he made it as a web component he
experimented with doing it in
react and angular and using basically
every library around to try and
go in this pursuit of learning web
components learning audio apis learning
how to break down a gif
learning how to i don't know what his
obsession is but he i think
his business card what did it say no
so if you if you don't know how to
decode a gif in a browser i think he
calls you a gif
enthusiast but he's a gift pro
anyway i'm going to show you a little
demo
of uh x gifts anyone seen x gift before
bunch folks cool okay so
x gif uh takes a gif you add a tag to
your browser just like you would an
image
you say here's the source of the gif and
it plays it just like an image
then some other cool stuff happens
you can actually change the playback of
the gif so you can do this ping pong
effect
and then you can even do other stuff
like uh how many times do you want the
gift to play through
just once and pause
and that's all implemented uh as
attributes the on the element which is
pretty cool
you can set the speed
you can set speed so you can say like oh
hey be really fast you're like crazy
stupid fast or just
then he started working on beats per
minute
and he figured out you could actually
sync some audio
so
mmm
oh pretty rough
so glenn is super rad uh he's my buddy
he's the css
guy as well uh you should definitely say
hi to him because i'm using his demos
and i'm kind of getting to play music
and
look cool but he's cooler than i am but
i think what's really interesting here
is that
x-give wouldn't have happened if we
didn't get drunk in the office and just
start hacking with gears
and this took glenn on a trip where he
started giving conference talks
at cascadia in portland at
js conf in melbourne at js conf in
berlin
and his conference schedule continues to
get booked
beyond today because of work like
ex-gift
so i want to set you a challenge
gift city started as a one hour
challenge and it led to
hours and hours of learning and super
amounts of fun
so i want all of you to go ahead and and
just do a dumb thing whatever the
dumbest thing is that you can come up
with that you think you can do in an
hour
just try and do it fact is if it's fun
and you actually achieve something an
hour you'll probably work on it for the
entire weekend but that's fine
i had another done project on fridays
we have a thing that we we run at our
office called jelly
jelly is casual co-working uh we have a
you know
reasonably sized office and we just like
to invite our friends to come in and
kind of work and just be around us and
go for lunch and have drinks together at
the end of the day
one particular jelly day i didn't feel
like doing actual real work
and i've never used bauer so of course i
should do something with bauer right
never used it i'd also never ever
written any python
i still have no idea what i'm doing and
i didn't even use
sublime text either so of course what am
i going to do in an hour i'm going to
write a sublime text plugin in python
that
uses bower so you can install bower
packages because
i don't know that's the most sensible
thing that i could do
in an hour i pulled something together
that kind of worked by reading other
people's source code
and over the weekend i tied it up and
released it
the last time i checked this plugin it
had over 10 000
installs and a lot of people actually
use it i don't use it so if
you've got some spare bandwidth and you
want to fix the issues
uh have a look at the issue tracker on
there but what was really interesting
here is that
after uh i worked on this i ended up
joining the bauer team
uh which was a totally unexpected result
i didn't ever use bauer before this
point of like riding this dumb thing in
python that i had no idea what i was
doing
and using an editor that i didn't use
either
which kind of gets me to a point about
open source
how many people write plus ones on
issues
yeah you're all jerks um i think uh
i i really hate this about open source i
really hate this like hey please go and
spend all of your time and do this for
me
because it really doesn't give anyone
anything and i want to let you in on a
little secret about open source
you can actually do open source without
doing anything
this is my strategy
watch listen learn and just help where
you can
so the reason i say this was because of
a particular circumstance that kind of
came towards me there's the old saying
if you don't know what you don't know
or in my case i would say you don't know
what you don't know until it literally
falls out of your head
for a little while i was
not a contributor not hadn't written any
code
uh the match media polyfill i was
interested in the match media polyfill
and i just started sort of trolling
around the issue tracker and following
it and
sort of looking at how it worked it was
a really simple little polyfill and i
thought it was cool
and about two years ago
an issue came in that said that we
should remove this code
there was a completely new pr that
rewrote all of this
and it was a huge pr basically rewrote
the entire library
and i spent hours reviewing it
remember i was not a contributor to the
to the open source project
and i just reviewed this and the code
was really good and so we talked about a
couple of little style things that we
wanted to fix before we accepted it
into the project but it got in and
months went on
one day i was in my team chat
with one of my clients and matt said
we've got a production performance issue
on mobile does anyone know what this
crazy minified code that says offset
with
triple equals 42 means and i had no idea
that i would know this
until he pasted it and as soon as he
pasted it i was like that's the match
media polyfill because i reviewed that
pull request
you know months ago and that's the only
thing that i could imagine that has
code that's this ridiculous and because
of that i guess i knew that there was
actually a new version of this polyfill
which addressed
these performance problems and we
upgraded it the bauer package
and our performance issue disappeared i
know that's a kind of a fun story
doesn't happen every time like that but
sometimes it does
how many of you uh build things start
building something
maybe work on it for a few hours and
never show anyone
everyone come on everyone does that
right i know you do you're lying we're
just late you're lazy or something
and almost forever uh particularly
earlier in my career i would uh
think of an idea and then 10 minutes
later i'd be writing code and
my girlfriend would say are you going to
bed anytime soon or are you going to
continue to be hacking on your laptop
and i would say
i am working on my laptop and i would
stay there and i would be working
past 2 o'clock in the morning on this
dumb thing um
and then i would wake up and i'd be
bloodshot going to work the next day and
basically hating my previous decisions
of working on this dumb thing
um but for a long time i didn't ship
these things they were half-baked and
like
they weren't really thought to the point
of like can i actually release this
and i think dumb experiments like that
are useless especially if you're not
going to commit to
actually showing somebody or actually
sharing it even with just one friend
maybe if you're at your work or
someone on the internet that you talk to
regularly
and for a little bit longer after that i
started bringing my friends into my dumb
projects
and i we also found the situation where
we'd start arguing about the project
before we'd even launched it or shown
anyone else
we're arguing about silly things that
didn't really matter because nobody else
knew this thing existed except for
one or two people so i'm going to set a
challenge for all of you here
the next time that you're going to build
something that you don't think you're
going to ship
i'm killing kittens
that guy too god he's so cute holy moly
so don't count your days make your days
count
work on projects that you think that
you'll ship work on projects that are
fun
work on projects that are dumb don't
necessarily do it for money
celebrate your wins when you do
something cool
enjoy it maybe launch something on your
birthday
right so for me i don't know about you
common birthday is you wake up and you
spend time with your partner or your
family
and then they say i have to go to work
today and you say okay i'm not working
today
and then the house goes quiet you sit by
yourself looking at twitter
it's pretty boring isn't it
so instead i decided to launch something
on my birthday this year
for the past year before i've been
working on an app called calibre
which is a quality and performance
telemetry suite for
the web it runs on chrome or it uses
chrome devtools everything that chrome
dev tools can get
caliber runs it runs against your site
every day or when you hit the api and it
gives you metrics about your site like
how quickly first paint was
what your css like quality is
like what you're um it records videos of
every time your site loads so that you
can compare them and like look at
screenshots of how long it took
something to render
or maybe you can blame a third party for
their ads being slow
so i've been working on this for a long
time if you want to check it out later
uh it's calibre app.com
but i launched it on my birthday and it
was the best birthday ever because for
the next
like eight hours i just watched my phone
be like retweeting and people saying hey
congratulations you launched something
that's really cool
so i want you guys to do that too
this is one of my favorite quotes uh by
ben period ben period worked on
supply which later sold to ebay which i
think he was maybe not so
proud of after uh because they did
nothing with it
they didn't ship it so i'm going to kill
a kitten for that he said
as a creative person you've been given
the ability to build things
by from nothing by the way of hard work
over long periods of time
creation is deeply personal and
rewarding
and it means that your work should be
rewarding as well
and if it's not then something's wrong
right we're spending all these hours
working on a computer typing in staring
at this goddamn stream
we should be enjoying that our jobs are
pretty great
and as a creative person you need to
understand yourself
i don't think you can underestimate the
importance of understanding what
motivates you as a person
and then working on that and
self-analyzing and getting better at
understanding the way that your brain
works
you got to figure out what makes you
tick you've got to figure out how to
ship
and as you do it you should repeat and
you should get better
you should make friends it's kind of
hard sometimes
and depression isn't really talked about
a lot in our industry
and like i said you and yourself alone
are the master of your own mental state
but you can help your friends and you
can help your colleagues
and not to mention minority groups as
well in short be better than you are
your career is long make it count
make it enjoyable and model your career
on
work that is not necessarily going to
make you famous or rich
but just work on stuff that makes you
happy iterate on that and when you
succeed
then worry about money it'll come
because if you don't it'll leave you
hollow
it'll leave you numb
sometimes you need to quit there's been
many situations through my career where
i've worried about a situation with a
client or with you know when i worked
for companies where
i hate it every day i regretted waking
up
i regretted going to the office i
regretted having to work with that
person that i didn't like that didn't
understand me because i'm special
and then you quit it all disappears
everything can be great
be ambitious if i had followed through
my career the
old adage of if you're not good at
something don't ever give it away for
free
i'd have missed out on amazing
opportunities to meet people
and to work on projects and you know
particularly becoming like
sort of friends with my heroes
i've always believed that sort of going
from the gut that i'm doing the thing
that
is the right thing to do and there are
times where i've strayed away from that
path
for a you know a project or a particular
job
sometimes for money working blissfully
is really important
and while there are times that you're
going to have to suck it up and just do
your job
those should be exceptions so if i had
any advice for
newcomers to our industry or any
creative pursuit
i'd say figure out what's important to
you and strive to get there
and don't be afraid to do what people
will tell you stupid
because if i had done that i would never
build all these ridiculous things that
have actually done
more for my career and more for me
enjoying working with people and
learning from people
than i had ever done in my commercial
career if i had just done the commercial
thing
i don't know where what i'd be doing i
probably would have quit by now
completely
honestly so believe in yourself and
trust yourself
and you'll build incredible things do
work that makes you feel good
start an event promote good work make
friends
encourage them have a really
good time
thank you